we're here in New York I'm also with
Joey Joey's here and you're not gonna
believe this so we're gonna go do that
Apple Store dance and this completely
layer I've done a lot of dances but I
did not recall the dance right here to
be remember I'm sorry but now I remember
I watched the video was that five years
ago probably oh my gosh five years ago
we're here and we're in New York for the
launch of our book and now we're gonna
dance at the Apple Store together for
the Klan it's gonna be great so shall we
go shall we going it does it smells like
a nice brand new MacBook that I just
opened up we don't get in trouble
I'm really not in the mood to get yelled
at today did I pass or dance that it was
fantastic it was very very exciting when
we posting it on Tuesday so make sure
you guys stay tuned for that and now
Joey a mannequin you know just because
like I'm you know really sore from
dancing and our hands like her just lay
bare on me so speedy something to be
touched on this your first pedicure I
guess the first time I thought it was in
Thailand mm-hmm and this is my first
time in America I just thought I'm in my
vlog cuz I don't think I did I'm not
even sure what I did today but I've been
really trying to make sure I do a little
daily vlog here on the book tour so this
is the end of today tomorrow is book on
and we're gonna be doing a panel with
Connor and Shane and Joey it's gonna be
really fun so hopefully I'll see you
guys there I'm sure you'll see vlogs
from all of our perspectives so with
that I will leave you with with a good
night and a good morning depending on
when you're watching this peace out
I'll see you guys on my first job in my
book tour in New Jersey Tuesday I love
you guys